THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP MET WITH
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS,
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS ON
THAT THORNY ISSUE OF IMMIGRATION
THAT THORNY ISSUE OF IMMIGRATIO
OFTEN IN WASHINGTON.
HE LET THE PRESS INTO FILM SOME
OF THE DISCUSSION.
LOOK AT DICK DURBIN -- HE'S ONE
OF THE PRESIDENT'S MOST VICIOUS
AS I HAVE BEEN SAYING FOR MANY
YEARS DURING THE ANTI-AMNESTY
BATTLES OF 2006, 2007, AND 2014,
THE PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO SEE
WHERE EVERYBODY'S CARDS ARE IN
THIS GAME OF HIGH-STAKES POKER
FOR THE NATION.
THE PRESIDENT MADE SURE THAT
HAPPENED.
>> President Trump: I WAS
SITTING WITH SOME OF OUR GREAT
REPUBLICAN SENATORS AND WE ALL
AGREED ON ANYTHING.
PERHAPS YOU WOULD LIKE TO SAY A
FEW WORDS?
AT >> WE CAN COME TOGETHER AND
REACH AN AGREEMENT.
I THINK THAT THINGS WILL HAPPEN
IN OTHER PLACES.
>> I HOPE THIS MEETING CAN BE
THE BEGINNING OF BUILDING TRUST,
I KNOW FOR A FACT ALL OF THE
REPUBLICANS AROUND THE TABLE ARE
COMMITTED TO FINDING A SOLUTION.
>> President Trump: WHERE ARE
YOU WITH THE BILL?
>> WE HAVE TO DO IT IN A
BIPARTISAN FASHION AND WE HAVE
TO PUT OUR BEST FOOT FORWARD.
>> Laura: SETTING ASIDE THE
SUBSTANCE OF THE NEGOTIATION,
THAT MEDIA STORY THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN PEDDLING FOR DAYS AND WEEKS
AND MONTHS THAT THE PRESIDENT
DOESN'T HAVE A HANDLE ON THINGS,
HE WAS CLEARLY IN COMMAND.
HE WAS GRACIOUS AND I DON'T
THINK HE COULD HAVE BEEN KINDER
TO THE 22 LEGISLATORS IN
ATTENDANCE.
LOOK AT THE WAY
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HEADLINE
CHARACTERIZED THE EVENT.
THAT IS JUST ABSOLUTELY PATHETIC
THAT IS JUST ABSOLUTELY PATHETI
PATHETIC.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS LIKE A
POWERFUL POLITICAL STRINGENT.
HE'S TRYING IN GOOD FAITH TO
NOTHING BUT GRIEF FROM THE
MEDIA.
REMEMBER WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA
HAD HIS ONE MEASLY ROUND TABLE
BEFORE THE CARE VOTE?
>> TREAT ALL AMERICANS THE SAME
SO THAT THEY WILL KNOW THAT
RECEIVE.
THANK YOU.
>> LET ME JUST MAKE THIS POINT.
BECAUSE WERE NOT CAMPAIGNING
ANYMORE, THE ELECTION IS OVER.
>> Laura: THAT WENT WELL, THE
PETTY AUTHOR MICHAEL WOLFF
NARRATIVE THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS NOT MENTALLY EQUIPPED FOR THE
JOB.
TODAY WE SAW HE'S SHARP, HE'S
SAVVY AND HE'S REALLY IMPATIENT
FOR SOLUTIONS FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IF ANYTHING, IT'S WASHINGTON
THAT'S NOT ABLE TO KEEP UP WITH
HIS PACE.
ALL THAT HE WANTS TO GET DONE,
I THINK IT'S ALL ABOUT TIME THAT
THEY TRUMP HATING MEDIA AND
POLITICAL ELITES, WHY NOT HAVE
THEIR OWN FITNESS FOR THEIR OWN
JOBS EXAMINED.
I THINK YOUR ABILITIES AND
FITNESS SHOULD BE MEASURED BY
YOUR TRACK RECORD AND YOUR
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OR LACK THERE
POLITICIANS IN BOTH PARTIES AS
WELL, STUPID POLICIES AND IDEAS
THAT DID ZERO EXCEPT WASTE OUR
HARD-EARNED MONEY OR SUFFOCATE
THE HOMELESSNESS, THE EPIDEMIC
THAT WE ARE SEEING UP AT IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES.
AS FOR THE PRESS, LET'S NOT
READERS INTO VIEWERS WITH THE
SAME OLD TROPES THEY TRIED
AGAINST TRUMP IN 2016.
>> HOW CAN YOU BE A RACE BAITING
XENOPHOBIC BIGOT -- WHICH
DONALD TRUMP IS -- DONALD TRUMP
STARTED TALKING ABOUT THE MUSLIM
MAN.
I KNEW IMMEDIATELY AT THAT
MOMENT I COULD NEVER VOTE FOR
THIS GUY.
>> Laura: HE'S SAYING TRUMP IS
GETTING OUT OF IT?
JEB BUSH COULDN'T WIN HIS HOME
CLAIMS OF A NASTY CRACKPOT
JOURNALISTS, REPORTERS SPENT
TIME ELEVATING THE HOPES AND
DREAMS OF AMERICANS OUTSIDE THE
SELLOUT COURT OR.
I THINK TRUMP IS GROWING INTO
THE JOB WELL.
HE'S ACCOMPLISHING MORE AND MORE
GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY THEN I
BELIEVE MOST OTHER PRESIDENTS IN
MY LIFETIME.
NOW AS FOR THE ACTUAL POLICY
ANALYSIS OF WHAT THIS BIPARTISAN
GAGGLE MAY DO ON IMMIGRATION,
THERE WERE SOME GOOD SIGNS AND
SOME NOT SO GOOD SIGNS.
FIRST LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
POSITIVE SPIRIT OF THE PRESIDENT
REITERATED HIS MUST HAVE IN ANY
DACA DEAL.
>> President Trump: A WALL HAS
TO BE BUILT.
CANCEL THE LOTTERY PROGRAM,
THOSE THREE THINGS ARE PARAMOUNT
THOSE THREE THINGS ARE PARAMOUN
PARAMOUNT.
>> Laura: IN A PERFECT WORLD
WOULD PASS THE ACT THAT TOM
COTTON, SENATOR PURDUE ACT
BEFORE WE TOOK ANY STEPS TOWARDS
REWARDING THOSE IN THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
GREEN CARD, WE SHOULDN'T DO IT.
NOW THAT THE CONCERNING PART OF
THE DACA ROUNDTABLE.
A BILL OF LOVE AND WE CAN DO IT.
WHEN THAT THIS GROUP BACK WITH
AN AGREEMENT FROM THE SENATE,
FROM THE HOUSE WITH AN
AGREEMENT, I'M SIGNING IT, I
OR I WANT THAT, I'M SIGNING IT.
>> Laura: I HOPE THE PRESIDENT
HASN'T BEEN READING THAT JEB
DESCRIBED ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AS
AN ACT OF LOVE?
LIKE CLOCKWORK HE TWEETED TODAY
ENCOURAGED THE PRESIDENT IS
SEEKING BIPARTISAN SOLUTIONS TO
OUR IMMIGRATION CHALLENGES.
I'LL BET.
COLOR ME CONCERNED.
WHILE THE PRESIDENT SEEMS EAGER
TO DO A DACA DEAL, I WOULD
CAUTION THIS IS NOT THE REASON
WHY HE WON.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ELECTED HIM
TO PROTECT THEIR SECURITY AND
WELL-BEING FIRST.
I HAVE FIVE THOUGHTS FOR THE
THE AMERICAN WORKER IN THE
LANGUAGE THAT YOU USE, EVEN WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT DOING SOMETHING
FOR THE DACA KIDS.
NUMBER TWO, TRUMP WON BECAUSE
HIS POSITION ON IMMIGRATION
DIFFERENT FROM EVERYONE ELSE'S
IN THAT ROOM.
WE NEED TO KEEP THE FOCUS ON
WHAT'S GOOD FOR AMERICAN
CITIZENS AND LEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
NUMBER THREE, LETS EVERYONE BE
HONEST -- PASSING DACA WANT TO
BE SOME MAGIC ELIXIR FOR
AMERICANS.
THE G.O.P. IS GOING TO BE
DRUMMED OUT OF OFFICE IF THEY
THAN AMERICAN CITIZENS.
NUMBER FOUR, IF WE DON'T CHANGE
OUR LEGAL IMMIGRATION SYSTEM AND
FASTED THE MELTING POT WILL
BREAK BEYOND REPAIR.
ASSIMILATION, PATRIOTIC
IMMIGRATION, AND MERIT MUST BE
CENTRAL TO ANY DISCUSSION.
IF WE DON'T GET THIS RIGHT, WE
WANT TO BE TWO COUNTRIES, WE'RE
GOING TO BE TEN COUNTRIES.
WE KNOW THEY CARE MORE ABOUT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THAN THE
WORKING AMERICANS.
THAT WILL BE GOOD FOR
REPUBLICANS, IT WILL BE BAD FOR
THE COUNTRY.
THE U.S. WENT FROM A 9 MILLION
IMMIGRANTS TO 45 MILLION
IMMIGRANTS COMING IN AND JUST
HALF A CENTURY.
THAT WAS THE LARGEST MOVEMENT OF
PEOPLE IN THE HISTORY OF THE
WORLD.
ON THIS.
THE PRESIDENT IS FULLY ENGAGED
AND FULLY COMMITTED TO THE
TRICKY AND OFTEN UNPLEASANT
WASHINGTON.
IF HE CAN GET THESE ENTRENCHED
ELITES IN D.C. TO SECURE THIS
BORDER AND FOCUS ON THE NEEDS OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THAT ALONE
WILL BE A MASSIVE VICTORY FOR
THIS PRESIDENT AND THIS COUNTRY.